news broke on December 12th that Andre
Brower star of Brooklyn 99 passed away
the day before at the age of 61
reportedly from a short illness in the
wake of this tragic news the official
Brooklyn 99 Instagram account posted
always our captain we love you Andre
across eight seasons from 2013 to 2021
Brower played Captain Raymond halt on
the series which originally aired on Fox
and moved to NBC for its final three
seasons the character was revolutionary
for police procedural halt was a strict
yet Fair Precinct Captain who before the
events of the show struggled throughout
his career because he was an openly gay
black Detective When audiences in the
precinct meet him halol fully Embraces
his identity and his Squad accepts him
without question do you Kevin yes and do
you yes yes we do we're married brow
start alongside a talented ensemble cast
on Brooklyn 99 while tributes are still
pouring in he has held a cast of this
below loved comedy responded to the
tragic news of browers passing so far
Terry Cruz who played Terren Terry
Jeffers on the show took to Instagram to
share his grief over the loss of his
coaster posting a head shot of Andre
Brower and a heartfelt message that read
in part can't believe you're gone so
soon I'm honored to have known you
laughed with you worked with you and
shared eight glorious years watching
your Irreplaceable Talent this hurts you
left us too soon thank you for your
wisdom your advice your kindness and
your friendship deepest condolences to
your wife and family in this difficult
time Durk bler and Joe mckin and Miller
who played Michael Hitchcock and Norm
Scully also took to social media and
posted messages commemorating brow and
the time they spent working with him on
Instagram bler wrote a touching post
detailing just how incredible brow was
saying fiercely intelligent remarkably
kind supportive generous and possessed a
deep and extraordinary talent and had
even more to offer I am devastated I
love him the 9 years I was able to work
with him and to just be in his presence
was truly a blessing my heartfelt
condolences go out to his family Miller
also posted on Instagram adding a
caption to a photo apparently taken
behind the scenes of Brooklyn 99 writing
an actor prepares sending love to
Andre's family and friends and all of us
who had the honor of working with him
throughout the series brow's character
never hides that he's a proud queer
black man and eventually we meet his
husband Kevin kosner played by Mark Evan
Jackson though the two experienced some
marital issues throughout the show they
end up together at the series conclusion
apparently my husband Kevin has invited
you all to my party there's very little
street parking no gifts no singing of
happy birthday should be fun Jackson
kept things simple on Instagram posting
a photo of brow holding him in a sweet
Embrace on Twitter and writing simply Oh
Captain My Captain Jolo trulio a comedy
veteran who plays a precincts favorite
OB Charles Bole wrote an extremely
touching OD to Brower on Instagram in
the wake of the actor's sudden and
shocking death L trulio posted a photo
of Brower laughing writing so many
wonderful stories will be told about
Andre but for now all my love goes to
his wife Amy and his three boys who he
loved very much and flew back every
weekend from the show to be with low
trulio went on to reveal that Brower was
extraordinarily focused on his family
noting that browers constantly spoke
about his love for them on set he also
talked about brow's passion for AC
writing we all know how powerful an
actor he was but even more Andre knew
exactly well his most important role and
was deeply proud of it I'm grateful to
them for allowing us to share 8 years
with him he was committed and passionate
about the things he loved the Brooklyn
99 star ended his tribute by expressing
how much he misses Brower adding what an
honor to work with a man who knew what
it was really all about I feel blessed
and thankful miss you Captain Hal love
pork
chop